there's 100 rationale to what time you
post and I'm talking not at night I'm
talking you might be in a place on your
platform where you need to be posting at
709 pm and most people are not going
that far I believe you have kind of a
superpower and just see how everything
Technologies Trends platforms will
unfold and shape the future do you agree
with the superpower and how important it
was for you to become what you have
become and like going forward you said
at the 24 months we'll have like the
most Transformations compared to the 10
last years how important this will be
for you and for our great this year
thank you my friend it's so nice to meet
all of you and congratulations to all
the people what you're doing
I do think it's a superpower but I don't
think it's a superpower that is not uh
replicatable what I said on stage about
maybe is very important my one of my
greatest strengths is curiosity I'm
curious and I'm and I'm willing to waste
time and even though my time is valuable
to understand what's happening now too
many people as they grow and Achieve
they become complacent or they want
other things my Hunger is to be great at
my craft
and my craft is to understand consumers
and to understand consumers you must
have no opinions you must just be
curious and you must have humility not
audacity I get a lot of credit for
predicting things right and somebody
will post and say look what garyvee said
in 2016 and sometimes comments will try
to razz me and go ah you can get lucky
if you're always predicting and I always
reply when I have time and I say show me
the video where I'm wrong right because
what I don't do is I don't guess I'm not
Nostradamus I'm not a psychic I take
things that have already happened when I
look what I did with AI a lot of people
like I I every single person stood up
it's happened
but it's early I and everybody else is
still trying to understand everything
about it but nobody here
can get away especially at the size and
the scale that everybody's playing here
you have a lot more to lose
you have a lot to lose when you have a
successful business
you to completely dismiss Ai and not
think how it might affect you
most people look at the negative ooh am
I in trouble will this hurt me I look at
it the positive how do I use this to
jump two spaces ahead so yeah I think I
do think my ability to understand what's
happening has been fundamental to where
I am today because it helps you do
everything it helped me build the
garyvee it helped me build the agency it
helped me sell wine it helped me build
be friends you know I'm gonna build one
of the next Pokemons one of the next
Disney's one of the next Marvel and it's
going to happen because of that because
you can't afford no business can afford
to overspend on things that don't work
every business can grow quite a bit if
it spends on things that are climbing up
so I spend very very serious time and
attention on trying to be good at it
so anyone has questions so he is in the
relationship niche
in their beauty and YouTube to
internationalize their business went to
another countries in English
and the question is what is the
fundamentals to internationalize yet go
abroad but should pay attention what is
what is critical of that
as technology
starts to grow all of our language you
know I'm going to come to this
conference in four years and the way we
translate me is going to be totally
different the mic will use Ai and smart
technology and I will literally talk and
it will literally be Portuguese it's
insane we're ready converting all of my
content to every language and the voice
it's literally me speaking and it's 85
there like it still it sounds like me
but not all the way
but it's me speaking French and German
and Portuguese and say it's insane so
first the big hurdle was language and
now that that's going to go away in the
next two three four years that's why
there's so much description
next will be culture
culture is how you internationalize
relevant in India
you may need to know something about
cricket
right my football is not your football
right these things matter now what we're
seeing is even without
the technology we're seeing a revolution
of cross-pollination of cultures
Korean pop stars are now famous
in America and Europe in summer I don't
have to tell anyone here of what's going
on with Bad Bunny or paluma or all this
stuff it's crazy it's amazing to watch
the world become more Global Because The
Internet Is global
you know when I was growing up 15 year
old girls in the middle of America MTV
was not playing Bad Bunny or J Balvin
today they can find it on Spotify or on
social media so the world's changing but
the variable for you to cross over will
be based on your ability to understand
pop culture in every market and how to
make your message fit the realities of
what's Happening
best practices
that's already interesting one I think
culture is really difficult to really
understand
even if you live there like two three
years it's really really useful to
really understand what is happening
how did you do that in some countries
they do higher low codes they send
people what is both
for me what I'm very good at the things
that people clap that here they clap at
in Dubai they clap out in Japan they
clap in America because one thing I
spend a lot of time on is fundamental
human truth
truth about humans are at its simplest
form life is about confidence and
insecurity
right that's true no matter where you
are but when I go to a country
if I'm gonna you know if I'm giving that
speech in San Francisco instead of using
popular footballers I may use popular
American footballers I interstitial the
culture into the context of the room you
do that by either being good at it
yourself
or by hiring people in Market or sending
people from your core team to go into
market and absorb the culture Yeah we
actually see this like on theaters and
things like this
if you don't have localized contacts it
doesn't land
relevance is what everyone's looking for
and if you're making a joke or a
reference you know the video you make on
YouTube that gets you know 100 000 views
in Brazil might be subtly on one little
thing that's happening in Brazil right
now that somebody in Chile or somebody
in South Korea doesn't even understand
thus not being able so that's where
these things are going to play out
cool nice question
I would like to ask you two questions
one more for yourself and the other one
more credit score and your video
Manifesto 2017 is my most favorite video
in the world and I would like to know
how does it work the thing that you talk
about how Bully from the opposite
interactions nowadays it's it's do the
same thing and talk about a little bit
about this Concepts and the other thing
is your strategy about
instead of creating now you you thought
that is
most Channel creates content and you
could speak a little bit about it first
of all thank you thank you thank you for
knowing both those things so let me
break them down in that video and back
to what I just said about human truths I
believe balance is everything
but people don't understand balance so
for me for example my conviction and
confidence and bravado is very high I
believe in myself I don't even think I'm
comfortable expressing how much I
believe in myself
that's luck of DNA that's my mother
there's a lot of things that went into
it but it's the truth I truly believe
that I am special and Ultra capable
on the flip side the reason it works is
because I think humility is the other
thing that makes me work
as much as I think I'm special I think
there's been many special people I think
there's many special people right now I
think there's been millions of special
people through the years of life and I
know that if God forbid I pass away
tomorrow that I will probably get a good
24 hours on social media everybody will
share their favorite video and if they
met me
so I believe I believe in being
competitive but being a sportsman I
believe in a lot of things that
seemingly look
opposite the biggest one I believe in is
in ambition and patience
almost everybody who consumes my content
when they hear patience hears
complacency not patience
right so I go so hard every day I mean
look at me what I'm doing now midnight
flight from New York fly here I'm
literally going to the airport right now
back to New York bagging up my body
going hard but I believe in patience
slow it will all come and so
the opposite directions pulling hard for
it's like a bridge
bridges are so powerful it's so hard to
get across the ocean but we built a
bridge why they're pulling hard
and I think for a lot of us we're
pulling from either one side or the
other
and we don't have that balance so it's
very much still the same
um as far as document don't create I
don't think that changes so there was
there was a period years ago where
in YouTube you started to see people
like Casey neistat and others they were
vloggers but they were videoing
themselves and I knew that I was not
capable of that but I knew that the
medium of YouTube was important and I
also started to know notice that people
were talking about entrepreneurship like
fantasy not reality and I thought that I
could help so I decided to have somebody
start filming me documenting me
so I was documenting my life not sitting
down and creating like an influencer or
a creator that is how I was able to
scale and build my brand by filming
everything and then post-producing
content what I'm talking about now is
the craft of being better in the
distribution of the content I still
believe in documenting
platform
nowadays we feel like
I need a real content and then I split
in every possible form it doesn't work
as well as in the past you know days I
feel like I have to make the video good
about it yeah I I think the way we do
that I do not but I but I do yes and no
what I said up there of like how
Instagram isn't as easy as it was a
couple years ago the the reason it's not
working as well as it did in the past is
there's more competition
thank you
it's not that you know the stakes have
been leveled higher it's like anything
else I was the best tennis player when I
was in fourth grade because I played
with six people and I was in fourth
grade as the competition got to high
school I wasn't and that's what's
happening you have to be much better at
the post-production it was so much
easier more things would go about it
because there was more attention and
less Supply now there's so much Supply
and the attention is staggered between
YouTube shorts Tick Tock Instagram right
so I think they're there is the
potential to be very on platform and
focus on Tick Tock and say I'm making a
tick tock and people see success with
that but it's because they gave a lot
more thought to that piece of content I
still think that they can chop up pieces
with best practices it just requires
more skill we feel it I feel it on my
brand we've got like my team knows
Dustin and ragam know the last six
months I've been on everyone I'm like
things have changed it's not as easy we
have to be better we're hiring more
analytics more math I'll give you a good
one there's 100 rationale to what time
you post and I'm talking not at night
I'm talking you might be in a place on
your platform where you need to be
posting at 709 pm
and most people are not going that far
or that Instagram is now searching
emojis for search like there's it's such
a complex game and it's getting more
complex
yeah me too like you know and uh you're
catching me at a funny time where you
know you go and you when I was talking
up there about being complacent and six
and three or twelve I'm talking to
myself
I'm at a very high level I want to
continue to go I got a lot of Ambitions
and I realize that we have to get better
at the way we're doing it because what's
what worked 18 months ago is not working
now
first of all thank you so much for your
content when I was hired in 2015
for work to run ads for a big player in
Brazil Bible for my job was to learn
English so I have to listen to you
my content on the internet I go to the
community in Brazil we we are traffic
practice players we do ads for our kind
of business I have a community with
[Music]
and I don't know exactly how to balance
the brand with the salad because the
selling is important to my business of
course I have to put the oxygen of
course it didn't work but I love to
create content yes for creating how do I
do this how do I balance the more
content versus the the Sabbath
the more you can make it about the brand
and less the more likely you'll make
more money it's it's been very obvious
watching everybody over the last 20
years it just depends on where you are
in your journey meaning let's just talk
percentages
a lot of people are 80 selling 20 brands
summer 90 selling 10 brands the great
goal is that you're achieving the
financial wants and needs and oxygen
that you need
my my ideal state is 80 brand 20 selling
in time and effort and energy and intent
in your soul and the money you spend but
there is no right answer everyone's in
different places but the consumer on the
other side
data is very clear the more you can get
away with not selling the more likely
you'll sell
on this stopping I'll build a brand
brand ability I think when a big
decision that we have in Brazil and a
lot of people growing this Justice on on
other hogmart events like when you think
about building a brand how important it
is to to detach the face of the Creator
to the brand versus using it a lot and
in which part of the journey I think the
main question is
to build a big big big company should
you start to detach it your face rent at
some point or how do you see that the
good news is this has already been
solved the answer is both
we've seen some of the biggest brands in
the world be very attached to a face
Ryan Reynolds builds very big brands in
companies right in the alcohol business
The Rock uses this thing and then you
know then we have enormous brands that
nobody nobody knows you know Jose Cuervo
you know like is a fictional character
or the name of someone who started the
brand but we don't know that person so
the good news is the answer is both
right people ask me about vaynermedia
all the time vaynermedia is a 300
million dollar business for two thousand
employees a big business and people like
how because they assume that I'm
servicing every client I service no
clients I'm a CEO so when now I'm very
well known but when when Nike or Reebok
or or under armor and secret if they
come to me the first thing I say to them
is this is vaynermedia we have an agency
of course I'm involved I can get on the
backbone occasionally but I'm not sure
this is your account I'm not creating
the content I'm not and so a lot of
people are scared to build a big brand
because of the person because they don't
realize how they get away from detaching
from the person it's very easy it's
called being upfront and transparent to
your clients very easy to use face very
easy to not use a face Bill Knight did
not use a space for Nike he used other
people's faces so but Ryan Reynolds has
built three exits major using his face
aggressively complimented with other
things so there's no right answer to
this both work and both don't work cool
hi Gary hi hi
I was thinking Portuguese no problem no
problem
teaches people about how to speak
publicly and perform well at the stage
and things like
things like Insurance talking about like
you have attention and
a computer told us about like the life
being a teacher and have all these AI
Revolution coming up how is going back
like how you differentiate your content
or Brands Like Everything Will Change
how much things you know it's funny it's
similar to a picture was talking about
when we were just talking about and I
was just talking about like
differentiation
is adjusting to the reality of the
situation meaning the answer is nobody's
really fully sure what AI is going to do
to all of this we just know a lot of
it's going to impact it then we're gonna
understand it and then you have to
adjust I think of this like boxing or
MMA like fighting you have a plan you
spend four months knowing you're gonna
fight each other
you I watched every video of every fight
I know that he normally uses his left
leg to do this I also know that he knows
I'm watching every single video of every
one of his sights and he might fake left
and go right and I make it knocked the
out
that's how this is gonna work I know
that Ai and new platforms and metaverse
it's all coming
I don't know exactly what's gonna happen
but I'm gonna have to adjust
and sometimes it changes everything I'll
give you an example influencers
influencers love that they become more
famous than famous people right they
think it's so cool that they're more
famous than actors and actresses and
footballers meanwhile right now as we
sit here today AI generated characters
virtual characters are streaming in Asia
and becoming more famous than people
literally robots non-humans are becoming
more famous as streamers and content
creators who are generating AI
characters they're gonna take their
money so the influencers have taken the
money from marketing from athletes and
actresses and they think they're the
king and queen now and as we sit here
today people are developing characters
that are virtual who are vlogging and
streaming and they're going to take the
money
the question becomes someone like me
some like him when you have the ability
as a human to do it okay but here comes
a character that can do it better maybe
using AI so I'm gonna have to adjust
what do I do maybe I start a company
that has characters that I use my
platform to build up the character
what's amazing about business and the
way the world works is there's only one
option to be prepared for the fight and
then the fight happens now we have the
first round and he did something
different now I have three minutes or a
minute before I go back out there to
figure out what he was doing and why he
was doing it and then ding ding ding and
we gotta fight that's business so what I
think what we the number one rule is to
be mentally prepared that what we all do
is always in trouble to changing and
number two as it's happening put in the
work to come up with a new thing to do
I'll give you know back to my public
speaking career in 2009 when I first hit
the scene in 2007 when I first hit the
scene
everybody said that I was not going to
be successful because I cursed and
because I rest casual I
didn't want to wear a suit and not curse
and I was willing to give up the money I
was willing to be myself I didn't know
the world was going to get more casual
I didn't know the business world was
going to get more casual up into that
point business was you know people
didn't wear off-whites people didn't
look they were it wasn't and now it
became the world it worked out for me
had I started taking bigger speaking
fees and became bigger of people who
were wearing ties and cordial and board
it just happened but like I said the
keynote speaker of this conference in
seven years might be a hologram
so look at the future in the next five
years
would you say there would be the most
important points that we have to keep in
our minds to still be the leader of
markets in the next five years
um you know what a beautiful way for
this to end I would argue the reason
knowing the makeup of those 8 000 people
I decided to frame my conversation up
there for exactly what I believe here
it's just that everyone here is more
advanced and has more to gain and more
to lose it's two things it's everyone
here has to continue on the path of
attention you have to
it's it's the game you can't sell
anything if nobody's listening so where
are they listening and where are they
listening at a better price people say
to me Gary television commercials still
work I'm like yes
Coca-Cola you spend 10 million dollars
on that commercial
of course you're gonna sell some
Coca-Cola but what if you spent 10
million on Mr Beast and YouTube and Tick
Tock what have you sold more
and so we have to not only pay attention
to where attention is we have to
understand we're underpriced attention
is and stay away from overpriced
attention just because we used to do it
all those people how many of you here do
Google AdWords Google beautiful right
the day the day Google AdWords came out
I bought every name of every wine from
my dad's wine store and was paying five
cents a click
thank you
my customer acquisition on hundred
dollar orders of wine was 39 cents
hard enough to know
every dollar my dad had in his life on
it but I wasn't smart enough to know how
good the underpriced attention was and I
think back to that day every day
the reason I've gone so hard at Tick
Tock were the new stuff now is I don't
want to make the same mistake I made a
22. all of us happened today
no wine turned missed five cents you
know and that customer acquisition is so
much more so attention and then
accountability
the biggest the biggest vulnerability to
everyone in this room my friend is their
success
[Music]
biggest reason people will not be in
this room in five years is
they got too high on their own Supply
they didn't keep fighting to innovate
they got complacent they got comfortable
they became fulfilled financially and
started and that's okay it's okay some
of you sacrifice time with your family
some of you sacrificed your health and
you want to be like that's okay
but it is the reason you wouldn't be as
financially successful if you you're not
constantly changing and you're not
realizing it's the biggest thing I hear
about
blaming their employees for their lack
of success when all of you hired your
employees and you can fire them
if you sit here today and are thinking
about an employee and blaming them for
something that's not working you're
deflecting responsibility every I always
say my company everything is my fault
because it is because if Dustin if
Dustin wasn't recording all day now and
it and like he forgot to hit record I
can understand how it sounds but I
picked us and I can I 4 000 people
wanting to be filming me every day in my
inbox every day I could have decided
he's not as sharp or he's not into it so
I think for a lot of you it's it's it's
the accountability everything's on you
you've got to constantly change to stay
on top and everybody that works for you
is your responsibility no matter how
much you pay them or what you put them
in charge of
so that was the last question about home
sure I'm heading back to New York okay
but thank you a lot Gary thank you my
friend thank you Victor
thank you everybody
foreign
[Music]